how often have you seen something not
quite right in your neighborhood but you
didn't know who to contact to address it
you'll be happy to know there's now a
way to report quality of life issues
as kirsten joyce tells us clark county
launched a new reporting tool today
kirsten brian it's an app called fix it
clark county where you can not only
report a complaint but track the
progress being made about that complaint
through the app
and the website all right let's say you
have an issue maybe you're upset with
some potholes in your neighborhood
the streets light aren't working there's
graffiti there
maybe there's trash being left or maybe
it's something along the lines of
short-term rentals in your neighborhood
homeless camping out nearby even
neighborhood businesses or restaurants
not following coveted protocol
all you have to do go to
clarkcountynv.gov website
click on fix it clark county where you
can tap on the problem you want to
report
you can also simply download the app as
we were saying commissioners say this is
the most convenient way for people to
report an issue and track its progress
neighbors can even create their own
watch areas to receive notifications
about the issues reported
and follow the progress of all those
requests
commissioners say residents are the eyes
and ears in the community
and they need your help identifying
matters that need resolving denise